Sara's with us in Des Moines Iowa hi
Sarah how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up well so
I was calling because um I need to know
what you suggest on getting my husband
on board he's doing everything I asked
him to he's following them a little
system he's doing everything like that
but he's not engaging or changing his
mindset and he doesn't want to be part
of the budget meeting what do you want
what should I do okay how old are you
guys but no more 29 we just got the news
in the end of September
oh wow you're brand new married yes and
we decided to start this okay cool
what's he do for a living
he's a apprentice Willis anytime and
what's his dad do for a living he's
retired what did he do for a living he
was and oh what's it called something
for DZ here in Des Moines he did like
research and development that's what
it's called okay do you think his mom
handled the money and his house growing
up yeah that's what I was guessing okay
so what I hear is a guy who works with
his hands and he's used to come up bring
bringing the bacon and coming home and
throwing it on the table and it's what
he watched his dad do his whole life and
mom took care of the money and so now he
just got married and he thinks it's
gonna work that way there because that's
how it works before we go yeah yeah
that's how it worked his whole life
watching it's the only model he's had
he's not a bad guy he's a hard-working
guy and his parents are great guys
they're great folks too there's nothing
wrong with that it just is not the most
efficient model and so he's looking at
you like you're from another planet when
you're describing this weird way of
doing things versus how he grew up yeah
so this is not like him being obstinate
or a bad husband you've been married a
whole month he can't be a bad husband Oh
perfect yeah well except for this one
little thing yeah
so what I would do is say is just say
this to him to say listen let's try
something different
I need your help as my man I want your I
want you to emotionally carry this
weight I don't mind doing the math part
but I want you to grasp where the
money's going so that we're making our
decisions our big decisions together
and then I'll write the checks out I'll
make sure the bills are paid and but but
I I need you to carry the weight of this
household with me as my man okay that
guy that we're talking about can hear it
if you say it that way
and this is what the TV off no
interferences and you're looking deeply
into his eyes I need you to ask my man
to help me carry the way to this house
that guy'll here that wony
well you can ask one more question yes
ma'am it's so I want to go to the money
and marriage here in Des Moines and he
does not think that we should go oh well
I'll give you a pair of tickets and
since you got free tickets now you have
to go hold on
[Music]